that's Sisyphus and meets a set of
Sisyphus if I remember correctly that
one has to imagine him happy well if
there's a rock at the bottom of the hill
then you might as well push it up the
hill and if it rolls back down well then
you've got something else to do don't
you can push the damn rock back up the
hill and there's no shortage of rocks to
put up to push up the hill and that's
what we're built for anyways and so
let's go out and like push some down
boulders up the hill and then maybe we
could have enough self-confidence and
enough enough respect for ourselves that
we wouldn't have to turn to hatred and
revenge and try to take everything down
because I think that's the alternative
so he's not weak that's one thing you
can say about him the same idea
represented there right that's outlets
who voluntarily takes the world on his
shoulders it's like the idea of Christ
taking the sins of the world on his
shoulders it's exactly the same notion
which is the notion that you should be
able to recognize in yourself all the
horror of humanity and take
responsibility for it because that's
what that means and the thing that's so
interesting about that is that if you
can recognize yourself in yourself all
the horror of humanity you will
instantly have a hell of a lot more
respect for yourself than you did before
you did that because there's some real
utility in knowing that you're a monster
now and just because you're a monster
doesn't mean you have to be a monster
but it's really useful to know that you
are one so then and one of the things
that you knew and this is something that
I find so amazing about his writings I
think something that really
distinguishes him for example from
Joseph Campbell who talked about
following your bliss is like Jung said
very clearly that the first step to
enlightenment is the encounter with the
shadow and what he meant by that was
everything horrible that human beings
have done was done by human beings and
you're one of them and so if you don't
understand that and to understand that
really means to know how it was that you
could have done it and that's a
shattering thing to try to imagine that
to try to imagine yourself as someone
who's engaged in medieval torture to see
how you could in fact do that
you're never the same after you learn
that but being never the same after
learning that is unbelievably useful
because when you understand that that's
what you're like
then you're a whole different creature
and I don't think and this is
something I did learn from young is that
you cannot be a good person until you
know how much evil you contain within
you it is not possible and it's partly
because you just don't have any potency
like if you're just naive if you're just
nice if you'd never hurt anyone you've
never heard of fly you don't have the
capability for any of that why would
anyone ever take you seriously you're
you're just you're a domestic animal at
best you know and a rather contemptible
one at that and it's a very strange
thing because you wouldn't think that
the revelation of the capacity for evil
is a precondition for the realization of
good but I believe first of all why
would you be serious enough to even
attempt to pursue the good unless you
had some sense of what the consequence
was of not doing it you have to be
serious about these sorts of things it's
not it's not it's not the game of a
child right it's the game of a fully
developed adult and you have learned
this in part when I had little kids I
wrote a chapter from my new book called
never let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them and why was that
and I read I read that wrote that after
I knew I was a monster and I thought I'm
going to make sure I like my kids I'm
going to make sure they behave around me
so that I like them because I'm Way
bigger than them and I'm Way more cruel
than they are and I've got tricks up my
sleeve that they cannot even possibly
imagine and if if they irritate me I
will absolutely take it out on them and
if you don't think that you're the sort
of person that would do that then you
are the sort of person who is doing it
[Applause]